okay if you're watching this video you
probably already know how to graph sine
and cosine graphs given an equation
but what do you do if they're giving you
the maximum and the minimum values and
you have to come up with the equation
that's what we're going to talk about in
this
video here so i'm going to go through
some equations with you some formulas
and then i'm going to show you also how
to kind of graph it and work with it
more visually
so we're going to do both and we're also
going to talk about how to write it as a
sine equation
and a cosine equation both so sinusoidal
means
basically that that shape of the graph
which is like an s type shape
so we'll write it both ways so the first
thing i like to do is draw a sketch
so here what we have is a pi comma 6 and
3 pi comma negative 2. so let's go ahead
and graph this 1 pi
2 pi 3 pi 4 pi
so pi 6 is right about here 3 pi
negative 2
is right about here and so you can see
the graph is looking
something like like that now what i want
to point out here
is that you know these graphs repeat
sine and cosine repeat
but from the maximum to the minimum
okay you see how that's only
half of one period so to go from
pi to three pi that's only half the
period so that's really like a
distance of two pi if we double that our
period is four pi
okay so now that's helpful now we want
to talk about
finding the amplitude and the vertical
shift
well notice that when you talk about the
vertical shift see this midline here
lies right on the x-axis okay it
basically divides the graph in half
half's above half's below
so the mid line here let's see we're
going from negative
2 to 6 let's see that's a distance of 8
half of that would be 4 1 2 3 4.
so you can see i'm just drawing in this
dashed or dotted line
this is our midline and normally that
midline we said was at the x-axis it's
been shifted
up 2 so that means that our k value here
is positive 2. now for the amplitude the
amplitude is like the height
of these waves and when you measure that
height it's like being on the beach it's
the
distance from the the midline to the
maximum or the midline to the minimum
the amplitude is always positive
if this coefficient here is negative
that means it's being reflected
over the x-axis but here what we can see
when you draw
a midline like we just did here is that
amplitude is a distance
from the midline so we could say one two
three four okay
our amplitude is four if you want to use
the formula
you just do the max which is 6
minus the minimum which is negative 2 6
minus negative 2 is like 6 plus 2 that's
8
divided by 2 is 4. so you can see we're
getting the same amplitude
with this k value the vertical shift
you're going to
add the max and the min divide by 2 so
that'd be 6 plus negative 2 is 4
divided by 2 is 2 so you can see we're
getting the same thing so if you like
the formulas use the formulas
if you like the graphing way use the
graphing way
now the only other thing we need to
figure out is this h value which is
related to this horizontal shift this
phase shift
and you can see that at the maximum here
for cosine see how this starts right
here on the y axis
but you can see this one's been shifted
to the right pi
so here our h value is going to equal
pi so let's write the cosine graph first
i find that to be a little bit easier
because cosine starts at the maximum
we've got the maximum
so let's write that out so we've got y
equals our amplitude which is 4
cosine okay now we have to find the b
value so the b value is related to this
formula here period equals 2 pi over b
so we have 4
pi equals 2 pi over b we can cross
multiply
so 4 pi b equals 2 pi and if we divide
both sides by 4
pi to get b by itself
you can see that b is coming out to
two-fourths which is one-half
so this is going to be one-half x
minus pi plus two
and that's our cosine equation now what
about the sine equation right mario
well you can notice that this the cosine
and the sine graph
they're out of phase by a quarter of a
period
see how cosine starts here at the
maximum
sine over here it starts actually at the
midline right and then it goes up to the
maximum but if you continue the cosine
graph
you know to the left here by a quarter
of a period
okay now see it looks like the sine
graph right
so the only difference between sine and
cosine is a quarter of a period
if we take the cosine graph shift it
left a quarter of a period but remember
when you shift it left
we're going to have to actually add a
quarter of a period
so a quarter of the period which is 4 pi
which is pi remember the one that's
grouped with the
x here has the opposite effect on the
graph so minus pi is shifting right pi
if this was plus pi which shifts left pi
so we're going to add pi here
to get our sine graph the amplitude's
the same
the period is the same the vertical
shift is the same but negative pi plus
pi
is 0 so we just get 4 sine one half
x plus two now you might be saying well
mario aren't there other answers
and you're absolutely right because
remember these graphs they continue on
and on and on forever and ever in
in both directions so what you can do if
you want other equations
is you can always add
multiples of the periods so for example
if i were to add 4 pi
here i could say x plus 3 pi
everything else would be the same or i
could subtract 4 pi i can say x minus 5
pi
and everything else would be the same so
that's just affecting the
the horizontal shift the phase shift now
what about you might say
what about making the amplitude negative
well you could do that
and you could you know reflect it and
work with a negative amplitude but in
this case i didn't really dive into that
but
sometimes that's helpful if for example
you had a graph
that was like like this and you can say
well hmm looks like a cosine graph
that's just been reflected so i'm just
going to maybe
figure out the amplitude and then put a
negative in front to reflect it over the
x-axis but in this case we didn't do
that
example if you want to see another
example to get some more practice with
this
follow me over to that video right there
and we'll dive into another example